nous en avons assez des mensonges, de la
moralité, de l'arrogance, nous en avons fini
avec votre programme pour saper la volonté des électeurs
et la liberté individuelle en Amérique
[Musique]
à chaque membre de la ligne des médias à
chaque faux Hollywood aux
athlètes modèles qui utilisent leur libre  discours pour
altérer et saper ce que notre drapeau
représente votre temps est compté
volonté et
liberté individuelle en Amérique, nous en avons fini avec votre
programme pour saper la sécurité de
vous de notre nation et les voix individuelles
du peuple américain à chaque
membre menteur des médias à chaque
faux Hollywood à ceux qui appellent
les lycéens payés crise  acteurs et refusé
d'écouter ton temps est compté ton
temps est compté les
horloges sont à nous maintenant
[Musique]
Je ne peux pas rester à la maison
et ne rien faire
je me sens mieux